comme des cartes postales poétique
disséminés dans plusieurs médiathèque de
saint quentin en yvelines ses poèmes
annonce le retour d'une saison
particulière le printemps des poètes
pour moi l'essentiel c'est de montrer
aux gens que la poésie est fait pour eux
contrairement à ce que ils ont pu penser
ou bien certains ont pu nous faire
accroire
elle est complètement accessible elle
est faite pour nous c'est pour ça qu'on
met des poèmes dans les bus qu'on met
des comédiens dans les bus comme et des
comédiens sur les marchés qu'on met des
poèmes dans les maisons de quartier
c'est pour bien montrer aux gens que
c'est fait pour eux une poésie
accessible cette année ce sont les
femmes qui sont mises à l'honneur des
poétesses du xxème siècle souvent
méconnu du grand public
en plus des poèmes dépôts et mathon sont
ainsi disséminer dans plusieurs villes
de saint quentin en yvelines
le poème at-on c'est une cabine une
cabine à poèmes comme un photomaton mais
au lieu de se faire prendre en photo on
se fait donner un poème dans l'oreille
on récupère le poème à la sortie les
gens viennent pour entendre des poèmes
et aussi partir avec dans la poche le
même qu'on va continuer à distribuer des
cartes postales politique en prose ou en
vers mais surtout en rimes voilà comment
devrait s'annoncer le mois de mars
utiles comme la pluie comme disait rené
guy cadou la poésie sera cette année un
rayon de soleil au milieu des giboulées